[Music]  English lessons if you've been to London  you might notice the local accent and  I'm not talking about cochlear I'm  talking about multicultural London ml  for short this accent is emerging novice  reaches history of immigration example  of ours for those that choose our banger  edict or that choose a banger isn't it  that means that's a great song if you  want to express yourself there's a whole  new world of vocabulary that you can use  some great ones are that's wack wicked  in it if you get me you know what's a ml  e is a social Lent which means  my wide range of young people in London  it doesn't matter what their social  classes they will put on their standard  English hello can I help you to get a  job but if they're speaking with their  friends they'll say all right May  yeah what you're up to language is a  living thing and it's changing every day  do you know what I mean by from London  [Music]